Il y a un an et demi,
ici, il n'y avait qu'un désert.
En octobre 1998,
un berger a trouvé une pierre bleue.
Un saphir.
Il a déclenché la ruée du siècle.
Trois-cent-mille personnes
s'entassent dans des campements
comme celui-ci,
éparpillés sur plus
de 800 kilomètres carrés.
Le plus important gisement du monde,
chacun de ces trous
est une mine de saphir.
Rasta est arrivé de Tananarive
avec trois copains il y a quatre mois.
Ici, pas de formalités,
n'importe qui peut creuser.
Une simple inscription suffit.
Rasta et ses copains
pensent avoir trouvé un filon
sur l'un des bords de leurs galeries.
La présence de cailloux est un indice.
Ils doivent d'abord sortir cette terre,
la tamiser, pour continuer.
S'ils veulent élargir leurs boyaux,
ils vont prendre des risques.
Dans la région, le bois vaut très cher.
Ils n'ont pas les moyens d'étayer.
Nous pensons que le saphir le moyen
le plus rapide pour devenir riche.
Tous ceux qui sont venus ici pour chercher
des pierres précieuses en ont trouvé.
Nous savons que ce travail
est très dangereux, suicidaire.
Si on veut devenir riche,
alors il faut accepter de risquer sa vie.
Ici, il n'y a pas d'argent facile.
Pour en gagner,
il faut se battre avec la mort.
À 500 mètres de leurs mines,
la rivière.
C'est là que Rasta
et ses trois copains
viennent tamiser la terre
qu'ils ont extraite de leurs boyaux.
Peut-être dans ce sable,
y a-t-il une pierre ?
Peut-être un beau saphir,
peut-être la fortune.
Ça fait quatre mois que
tous les jours ils l'espèrent.
Tout le monde assiste à l'opération.
Non pas qu'il n'ait pas confiance,
mais il vaut mieux éviter la tentation.
Laisser deux membres de la bande seuls
pour laver la terre,
ce serait peut-être en cas de découverte,
les amener à trahir la parole donnée.
On a trouvé que de petites pierres,
jamais de grosses.
En tout, on a gagné environ
deux millions de francs malgaches,
ce qui nous permettra de vivre
jusqu'à ce que l'on trouve le bon filon.
On essaye d'économiser
pour tenir le plus longtemps possible,
mais c'est dur
de travailler le ventre vide.
Ilakaka, au bord de la nationale sept,
la principale route du pays.
Il y a un an et demi,
c'était un arrêt d'autobus.
Il y avait sept maisons de terre,
et 85 habitants.
Aujourd'hui,
c'est la capitale du Saphir.
Tous les jours, de nouveaux arrivants
viennent y chercher fortune.
Ils viennent de tout le pays,
convaincus qu'à eux-aussi,
la chance va sourire.
Deux fois par semaine
à quelques kilomètres d'Ilakaka,
une dizaine d'hommes armés attendent.
Deux fois par semaine,
ce petit avion vient se poser devant eux.
Ils sont là pour accueillir le plus gros
acheteur de pierres précieuses du pays.
Bonjour. Ça va ?
Bonjour à tout le monde.
Werner Stalder Einstein est suisse.
Il a été attaqué une fois en Tanzanie.
On lui avait volé 500 000 francs.
-Bonjour. Ça va ?
-Depuis, il se méfie.
Vous avez toujours
un comité d'accueil comme ça ?
C'est une région dangereuse.
Il y a toutes les semaines des attaques
contre les thaïlandais,
les sri lankais, les acheteurs de pierres.
Qui les attaque ?
Je ne sais pas.
Werner ramène du cash.
À chaque voyage, 800 000 francs français,
une fortune ici.
Les sept kilomètres séparant l'aéroport
de la ville sont les plus dangereux.
À l'entrée de la ville,
le comptoir des Saphirs.
C'est où les acheteurs s'installent,
et que les prospecteurs tentent
de vendre leurs trouvailles.
Ils ont tous entendus l'avion de Werner.
C'est un bon acheteur.
Même les petites pièces l'intéressent.
Dans ces sacs,
les billets.
En francs malgache, 800 millions,
mille fois plus que nos francs.
Les prospecteurs savent tous que le suisse
repart une fois tout son argent dépensé.
Il vaut mieux
ne pas être dernier.
Ceux qui ont escaladé les murs
doivent sortir.
Ceux qui ont fait la queue
entrent en premier.
Werner aime l'ordre.
Il a conçu et organisé son comptoir.
Avant, il y avait beaucoup trop de gens
devant ma fenêtre.
Il y avait toujours des bagarres dehors.
Mes pierres se sont perdues.
Maintenant, c'est un par un.
Comme ça, on n'a plus d'histoires.
J'essaye de faire le plus vite possible
pour recevoir tout le monde.
La technique de Werner,
ne pas perdre de temps.
Acheter presque tout ce qu'on lui propose.
En gros parfois dans le lot,
il y a des pierres plus intéressantes.
On trouve des saphirs
de toutes les couleurs,
mais les bleus
sont les plus recherchés.
Couleur, grandeur, inclusions et formes
conditionnent mes prix.
Lorsqu'on lui propose
un bleu, Werner est plus attentif.
Ceux-là valent beaucoup.
Werner fixe son prix en quelques secondes.
Il n'a pas l'habitude de marchander.
Ils sont allés se concerter
à propos du prix.
Si on ne tombe pas d'accord,
on rend les pierres.
On n'est pas d'accord.
- Pourquoi ?
- Le propriétaire veut 15 millions.
Monsieur Werner propose quatre,
donc ce n'est pas accepté.
Joseph est agriculteur.
Avec Gervais, son fils, ils ont abandonné
leur lopin de terre à 600 kilomètres.
Ce qui les a décidés,
leurs voisins devenus riches ici
en quelques semaines.
Je ne connais pas les noms,
mais je crois que sont de vraies pierres.
Je veux les vendre
à peu près à un million de francs
- Un million ?
- Un million de francs, voire 500 000.
Puisque je suis totalement dépourvu.
Il n'a pas voulu acheter.
Puisque c'est trop petit.
- Il n'a pas dit le prix ?
- Non, les pierres sont petites.
Il n'a même pas proposé un prix.
Comme le dit Joseph,
lui et son fils sont totalement dépourvus.
Cela fait trois mois qu'ils sont arrivés.
Trois mois qu'ils n'ont rien gagné.
Quand ils sont arrivés, Joseph et Gervais
n'avaient pratiquement plus d'argent.
Tout était passé dans le voyage,
mais ils avaient des provisions,
de quoi tenir.
Joseph pensait qu'il suffisait
d'une bonne pelle, de beaucoup de sueur,
et peut-être aussi d'un peu de chance.
Un peu de chance pour que la misère
ne soit plus qu'un mauvais souvenir.
Je suis venu ici espérant gagner
comme les autres.
Des milliards ou bien des millions
pour changer la vie de notre famille.
J'ai fait ici trois mois.
Jusqu'à maintenant,
on n'a encore rien.
On travaillera
encore et encore jusqu'à trouver.
Il ne nous reste plus
que des petites provisions.
Du maïs,
10 kilogrammes de riz.
Dans le coin où Gervais creuse,
il n'y a plus de prospecteurs.
Ici, personne n'a trouvé de bons saphirs.
Joseph et son fils
sont les derniers à y croire.
Ils en sont à leur cinquième trou,
mais ils continuent.
C'est Gervais qui va au fond.
Son père remonte les déblais à la surface.
Si le boyau s'effondre,
Gervais ne pourra compter
que sur son père pour l'en sortir.
Aucune autre aide.
Là-haut, Joseph est seul.
Jusqu'à présent,
personne n'a échappé à un effondrement.
Il n'y a jamais eu de miracle.
Les éboulements tueraient en moyenne
quatre prospecteurs chaque semaine.
Ça fait plus de trois mois que je creuse.
Je n'ai toujours rien trouvé.
Je ne me décourage pas.
J'ai l'espoir de trouver un gros saphir.
Mon père et moi avons quittés
notre village à cause de la pauvreté.
Si l'on a la chance
de trouver des bons saphirs,
on deviendra tout
de suite riche.
Dans ce travail,
il faut bien contrôler tous ses gestes.
Par exemple, il ne faut pas creuser
une galerie trop large,
sinon elle risque de s'effondrer.
Il ne faut pas creuser le plafond
en carré parce qu'il ne tiendra pas.
Il faut faire les plafonds de galeries
en forme de voûte.
C'est moins dangereux.
Ferdinand a dix ans, lui est né ici.
Un des 85 habitants d'avant la ruée.
Il faisait le guide pour les touristes
qui s'arrêtaient sur la nationale,
un débrouillard.
Ferdinand a vite compris.
Il a vu des fortunes se faire.
Il a aussi remarqué que les prospecteurs
ne savaient pas tous bien vendre,
qu'ils avaient peur
de se faire avoir par les étrangers.
Des acheteurs qui viennent ici
avec leurs quatre-quatre.
Depuis, Ferdinand est devenu un courtier,
un intermédiaire.
Qu'est-ce que tu regardes dedans ?
Tu vois quoi ?
Il ya un peu de bulles.
- Il y a un peu quoi ?
- Bulles.
- Là, on voit. Tu as vu ?
- Pourquoi tu la mouille ?
Comme ça,
on voit les choses qu'il y a dedans.
- Combien il veut ?
- Pardon ?
- Combien il veut, lui ?
- Un million.
Combien tu lui proposes ?
Je propose 250 000, mais il ne veut pas.
La première fois,
j'étais avec ma maman,
et c'est elle qui m'a appris
à reconnaître le saphir.
C'est elle qui m'a ramené ici.
C'est une chance
qu'il y ait le saphir ici.
En ville j'étais guide
et je ne gagnais que 25 000.
Ici, je peux acheter un saphir 40 000
et le revendre à 250 000.
C'est une chance pour moi.
J'en suis très content.
Ferdinand a quelques rabatteurs
qui travaillent pour lui.
Il leur donne 10 pourcent.
Celui-là est venu le chercher,
car il a repéré une femme
qui veut vendre quelques pierres.
La femme au chapeau rouge.
Ferdinand a vite appris,
ni lampe, ni loupe.
Pourtant, il remarque tout de suite
la pierre intéressante.
Il y a quelques jours,
Ferdinand s'est retrouvé
avec un pistolet sur la tempe.
L'homme est parti avec tout son argent.
Il essaie depuis de faire attention.
- C'est une bonne pierre ?
- Oui.
Il va tenter sa chance
auprès d'un thaïlandais.
Les thaïlandais sont ici les acheteurs
les plus nombreux,
mais ils sont très exigeants
sur la qualité.
Ce que tu as ne coute rien.
Tu as acheté à 40 000.
Tu ne vas pas la vendre à Werner ?
- Je vais vendre.
- Le thaïlandais dit quoi ?
Pardon ?
- Le thaïlandais t'a dit quoi ?
- Que ce n'est pas leur qualité.
Regarde-moi faire avec Werner.
Il va me proposer un bon prix.
Sept-cent-cinquante-mille.
- Deux-cent-mille.
- Bloqué.
Deux-cent-mille, ce qu'il avait acheté
40 000 à peine 10 minutes plus tôt.
Deux-cent-mille francs malgaches,
le salaire mensuel
d'un ouvrier à Madagascar.
J'ai tout appris dans la rue.
J'ai appris le français, les saphirs,
j'ai tout appris dans la rue.
Ferdinand a une petite amie.
Elle a 12 ans et s'appelle Olga.
Leurs relations sont parfois empreintes
de quelques tensions.
Voilà quelques jours qu'Olga lui demande
de lui offrir une paire de chaussures.
Olga aussi gagne de l'argent,
mais son commerce est d'une autre nature.
Qu'est-ce cette petite fille
fait dans la vie ?
Elle fréquente les garçons.
Qui ? La fille ?
Avec quels garçons ?
Les thaïlandais ?
Oui. Des thaïlandais,
des malgaches et cetera.
- Quel âge as-tu ?
- J'ai 15 ans.
Olga ment, elle n'a que 12 ans.
L'orage inquiète toujours Werner.
Les nuages amènent une pénombre
dont il se méfie.
Il est obsédé par la sécurité.
C'est fini ?
Oui, on arrête à cause du temps.
Il va pleuvoir.
Comment s'est passée la journée ?
On n'a rien d'intéressant,
que des pierres moins chères.
Le sac aux billets est loin d'être vide,
mais il a décidé de partir.
C'est fini pour aujourd'hui.
Werner sait à peu près ce qu'il a acheté,
mais pas question de s'attarder.
Toujours son obsession de la sécurité.
C'est à Tananarive,
bien protégé chez lui, qu'il fera le tri.
Le voyage à Ilakaka vaut le risque.
Ici, on achète les pierres
cinq fois moins chères qu'au Sri Lanka,
l'autre grand producteur.
Vous avez fait des bonnes affaires
aujourd'hui ?
Il n'y a pas beaucoup
de pierres en ce moment.
Pourquoi ?
Le bruit court que les gens d'ici
veulent attaquer
ceux qui sont venus d'ailleurs,
du nord, du centre ou de l'est.
Depuis à peu près deux ou trois semaines,
il n'y a plus beaucoup de pierres.
J'ai seulement dépensé
le moitié de mon argent.
C'est possible de voir les pierres
que vous avez acheté ?
Non, je n'aime pas tellement.
Au revoir.
La maison de Ferdinand.
Il y vit avec sa mère,
ses cinq frères et sœurs.
C'est lui et son grand frère
qui font vivre toute la famille.
Le grand frère est prospecteur.
- C'est ma maman.
- Il est où ton papa ?
Mon papa est déjà mort.
Lui, c'est le fils de mon frère.
C'est ta maman qui l'élève ?
Oui. Il habite ici.
Mon frère est parti chercher les saphirs.
Que tu fais avec l'argent des pierres ?
Je vends des pierres,
puis je donne l'argent à ma mère.
Tu as déjà gagné beaucoup ?
Pas beaucoup.
J'ai gagné 2 500 000, maximum.
J'ai donné deux millions à ma mère,
et j'ai gardé 500 000.
C'est le vélo que j'ai acheté.
Il a quelques problèmes.
Il manque la selle et les pédales.
J'achèterai un autre.
- Combien l'as-tu payé ?
- J'ai payé 600 000.
Gaspard est un des premiers
à être venu à Ilakaka.
Il était étudiant dans la grande ville
la plus proche, Tuléar.
La rumeur du Saphir y est arrivée vite.
Il n'a pas hésité à venir ici
avec sa femme et son frère.
Gaspard a su saisir sa chance.
Il a réussi.
Aujourd'hui c'est un patron,
en franc malgache, il est milliardaire.
Dans sa voiture
quelques-uns de ses ouvriers.
En un an, Gaspard a vu arriver
des tas de prospecteurs.
Tout autour de chez lui,
les voisins creusent.
Les autres qui habitent à côté
de nous ont trouvé tout ça.
Quelquefois, les autres
enlèvent des maisons.
Parce qu'ils pensent que dans cette terre,
il y a des pierres précieuses.
Gaspard a compris
qu'il fallait trouver le bon emplacement,
et le bon filon pour s'en sortir.
Sa mine a un surnom,
la banque suisse.
Il emploie dix ouvriers qui ont creusé
jusqu'à la nappe phréatique.
Des pierres, il en a beaucoup trouvées.
En moyenne pour 20 millions
de francs malgaches par mois.
Plus il creuse,
plus il en trouve.
Tous les matins, ils vident l'eau du trou
qui s'est rempli la nuit.
Gaspard a les moyens.
Beaucoup de ceux qui sont venus au début
ont eu de la chance.
Lui n'a jamais creusé car dès son arrivée,
il a fait une superbe affaire.
La première fois,
j'ai eu une grosse pierre.
J'ai l'acheter à sept 7500 francs.
Je l'ai vendu au thaïlandais à 5 millions.
C'est là que j'ai commencé
à avoir de l'argent.
Six-cent-soixante-six fois la mise.
Des affaires comme celles-là,
il en a fait d'autres.
C'est ce qu'on appelle
le blocage en malgache.
Quand on a de tel blocage
dans la carrière,
c'est une indication
qu'il y a du saphir dedans.
Puisqu'ils sont dans le blocage,
effectivement, ils trouvent des pierres.
En arrivant ici, j'ai étudié la pierre,
le défaut, les bulles, la cassure.
Ça, c'est très bon.
Ça coûte entre 50 et 100 000 francs
Ses dix ouvriers, auxquels s'ajoutent
quelques extra journaliers,
sont tous d'anciens prospecteurs
qui n'ont pas eu de chance.
Gaspard a le sens de l'entreprise.
Les premiers à l'avoir rejoint
sont intéressés aux affaires.
Je partage les bénéfices avec
ceux qui ont commencé le travail avec moi.
Cinquante pourcent pour eux
et 50 pourcent pour moi.
Je paie 10 000 francs
par jour aux travailleurs journalier,
Gaspard se rend tous les jours
au comptoir du Saphir.
Là aussi, il y a des affaires à faire.
Il ne vend pas à Werner le Suisse,
mais à des acheteurs thaïlandais.
Ils sont nombreux, près de 300.
Les plus grands spécialistes du saphir.
les plus attaqués également
par les bandits.
L'homme prétend posséder dix armes
à portée de main.
Il y a un an et demi,
Gaspard a interrompu ses études.
Grâce au Saphir,
il s'est acheté une maison à Tuléar,
sa ville natale, et cinq taxis.
Il sait que les pierres précieuses
ne seront pas éternelles.
En tous les cas,
il a besoin de respectabilité.
Il me faut dans la vie un double emploi.
Je pense faire l'école normale
d'administration
à Tananarive,
et là, j'attendrai le poste.
Si par exemple je suis
sous-préfet ou directeur,
je vais toujours faire le business.
Effectivement, une partie
du gros business, c'est à Tananarive.
C'est là qu'habite Werner,
le suisse.
C'est là qu'ils se sentent en sécurité.
Chaque année,
je gagne normalement 20 à 15 pourcent.
- Seulement ?
- Oui, c'est en fonction de la quantité.
Ça coûte combien ce petit morceau-là ?
Je l'achète à 200 000,
ça veut dire 30 dollars.
Le bijoutier revendra
à 100 dollars à peu près.
À en croire Werner, des petites marges.
Certains font d'énormes profits.
Les spécialistes estiment
que chaque mois à Ilakaka,
il se négocie des saphirs
pour 120 millions de francs français.
Une estimation, car à Madagascar,
on n'aime pas parler de l'argent du saphir
l'un des plus beaux du monde.
Dans les mines, d'Ilakaka,
il en resterait assez
pour 200 ans d'exploitation.